simpatizantes de donald trump muchos de
ellos sin máscara han venido a
manifestar su apoyo acá en la marcha
mega mini en marcha una marcha que va
desde field en plaza hasta la corte
suprema de justicia máximo órgano
judicial al que donald trump le pide una
investigación por un supuesto fraude
donald trump en su cuenta de 'twitter'
apoyo esta marcha y pasó hace unas horas
por acá en su caravana para saludarlos
estoy acá para apoyar a donald trump
presidente de los eeuu por los próximos
cuatro años y parar la corrupción es una
epidemia de américa especialmente entre
los demócratas y liberales
esto no ha terminado ustedes votaron por
él en cuatro años absolutamente 100% si
su hijo o hija se lanzan a la
presidencia absolutamente ellos tienen
los mismos valores si ellos apoyan a la
gente baile no está por la gente baile
en esta por china él nos vendió a china
creo que él nos vendió a china marchas
en contra de donald trump se han dado
también alrededor de la ciudad y acá
también en la corte suprema de justicia
donde la policía tuvo que hacer una
separación con bicicletas para evitar la
violencia
yo bailé insiste en la unidad cree que
va a lograr la unidad y cómo lo va a
lograr
job airén insiste en la unidad cree que
va a lograr la unidad creo que la unidad
es un lema fácil de vender creo que eso
es bueno en teoría pero no en la
realidad unidad es lo que pide yobái del
presidente electo independientemente del
color político quiere gobernar para
todos pero hay quienes le dicen que esa
prioridad no es adecuada porque muchos
no lo reconocen como presidente